beginning in 2013 women from all over
the world left their homes to join Isis
thousands of these women remain in Syria
and Iraq where they continue to
fundraise and spread the group's
ideology but women also played prominent
roles in combating Isis from Jordanian
fighter pilots to Kurdish infantry units
women were on the front line we
shouldn't be surprised women formed a
significant minority of fighters in some
of the world's longest-running conflicts
including the civil wars in Colombia and
Sri Lanka women have served in many
roles and armed groups maintaining camps
and serving as medics and fighters while
many women take up arms for the same
reasons as men my research finds that
women are more likely to fight when
their homes families and safety are at
stake an armed groups ideology also
matters women are more likely to join
groups that fight to protect and expand
their rights the rise and fall of Isis
demonstrates that whatever woman's
motivations are their participation is
now a fundamental feature of war does
women's growing participation in armed
groups complicate the nature of war let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI